[Music]  the fire started way up on top of -  yellow and it made a real quick run down  the hill because being pushed by those  15 gusting to 30 mile an hour winds some  spots even higher and Montecito they  recorded 55 mile an hour down canyon  winds as it came down this Canyon it  also created spot fires they were  jumping up to a mile ahead of it as you  can see the fires crossed 154 and now  it's draining going down this Canyon  the San Antonio Creek Canyon that's  going to make a run down an area toward  some homes which we hope we can defend  and we hope we can stop it before it  gets there  the fuels are very dry that on top of  all the years of drought and we're still  short with the rainfall amount so we're  going to be looking forward to the  upcoming rain